the jurgen experience
i like uh helping folks that you know i
had um
i grew up in queens in in howard beach
and it was uh
for whatever reason organized crime
capital of the world and this is gonna
sound crazy but my neighbor was one of
the big bosses
and one day when i was pre-teens he said
to me you know the best thing we could
do on this
earth i said what he said help people
he's a guy that killed people for a
living
and um because that that was his his
perspective was he
he was a protector right he would help
people even though right from the
outside we know
what they really do but um but it stuck
with me
gotta help people so this was one of
those people i helped
isn't it crazy that sometimes even
people that are just
you would look at them they're like
they're bad people they have
some good advice like even morons can
occasionally say something
like huh all right i got that you know
like every now and then like even even a
real fool
will say something that makes a whole
lot of sense he changed my life this guy
he
he um he said to me
my parents were going through a divorce
i'm 12 years old and
he he wants to help me so he says come
over you're going to clean our swimming
pool
for us i'm going to pay you 35 a week so
um
i come over on saturday morning he says
all right the first lesson
he sit me down for lessons first lesson
is uh if you're going to come at 8 am
you show up 7 45
right on time is late great lesson for
life
second lesson is uh if i'm paying you to
clean the pool
i want you to straighten up the shed
straighten up all the lawn furniture
clean the windows do whatever the [ __ ]
you have to do but make it so that when
i get home i can't live
without you you are you know
irreplaceable as far as a service
provider
and number three never ask for money
you'll get paid if you do a good job
and it just stuck with me for life and
and
really really good lessons from a nun
like you say like a most unlikely source
yeah of advice well you know
not all mob people are bad people that
sounds like a crazy thing to say but
i you know i've known quite a few of
them in my life and some of them were
genuinely good guys they were just in a
[ __ ] up line of work
a [ __ ] up line of work well you know a
lot of them thought of themselves as
soldiers
you know they really did they thought of
themselves as soldiers in
an ancient war that you know we're not
going to understand you know we're not
talking about people that are
you know shaking people down for money
i'm talking about
you know people who were doing work
for other organized crime and they
looked at the government as criminals as
well
they were like they're all criminals
wall street you don't think they're
[ __ ] criminals
that was the exact as a young person
growing up in that that was the exact
narrative i heard
as i was being indoctrinated yeah um
that the government was just as bad they
killed people from
these guys that's what they were saying
to me um wall street does it with a pen
mm-hmm what the [ __ ] are you looking at
cops playing evidence yeah yeah
so so um yeah i'm not defending them
no but that was good the mob's not
around but that did a great job with
vegas
they did a good job it ran vegas very
nice
this guy ended up giving me um
700 customers by the time i graduated
college that worked oh so you had a
whole pool cleaning business
a giant business wow knock on wood uh
that were mostly
connected to
[Laughter]
and and i became friends with uh all
these guys
wow and could just go on anybody's it
was pretty unbelievable it's it's pretty
surreal thinking back
uh and i wanted i want like who wouldn't
want to be that you're a young kid
you're in this neighborhood they got
money respect beautiful cars like
i want to be that that's the problem
with that and
you know with young kids growing up
around gang members or drug dealers like
you look at that and you're like
they they have things that i don't have
and they live this life they get respect
from people
yeah they're feared yeah you know it
looks attractive
and and um one of the boss's wife said
to me one day because i
you know i was alluding to like you know
how do i how do i get my
um my make my bones and uh
she said this isn't i had red hair light
skin everybody else had dark hair dark
skin
and uh this isn't for you you stick with
cleaning pools this was from the wife
oh good one of bosses so um yeah that
kind of
set me straight